there are so many ways in washington to
say no
there's so many ways to kill an idea
there's so much risk
aversion in how we operate uh
and uh that it it it's it's a
herculean feat to do anything major but
when it happens when you do a sustained
mobilization that isn't just a
presidential campaign but
continues to fight which you've done for
uh cash
uh relief then you see that things can
get done and can change and so i have
admiration for your supporters that
they've
stuck with this stuck with you and have
gotten more engaged more involved after
your campaign than just saying okay we
did our thing and
we made our contribution to this country
i'm reflecting
on the fact that look if 55 of us are
for universal basic income
problem solved right and then it's like
problem not solved at all because of the
stuff that you're
[Music]
describing
[Music]
welcome back to the next episode of yang
speaks it's good to be with you all
thank you for tuning in ro khanna is
joining this episode this episode is
going to be
amazing uh so thanks for being here i'm
zach grauman i was andrew yang's
campaign manager
for our presidential run in 2020 and i'm
your co-host of yank speaks first things
first guys check out the new digs
i know it's not great i've you guys have
been trashing me
hilariously on twitter about my backdrop
i agree it's not been great
and it's not done yet still work in
progress become it like
a little better thank you all for those
of you who tuned in to our first episode
of our limited series the future of
we did the future of buying an
e-commerce last thursday
thursday episodes are back folks get
ready get excited
the feedback's been really positive so
thank you all for that and for the love
so tune in every thursday for thursday
episodes on our future and this week
we're talking about why
texas the entire state just froze over
why there's snow
and ice and problems in texas it's the
climate change episode folks
the future of energy so we've got
professors on who are experts in carbon
capture
i've got experts are um in the global
health effects
of climate change and i've got a forbes
30 under 30 entrepreneur
who's built one of the first power
plants that can capture the energy burn
from coal
way more efficiently really exciting
conversation you guys are gonna love it
so that's this thursday thursday
episodes
are back get excited that's number one
number two
speaking of texas i hope you all got a
good laugh
a very dark laugh i guess on cancun
cruise
so those are you in case you haven't
noticed this i heard about this senator
ted cruz yes the same center who's
said he would play andrew one on one in
basketball and then just bailed
uh he bailed again he in the middle of
this historic crisis
in texas we've got millions without
power and water and heat
just left to cancun just up and left
which is ridiculous now look
i don't judge people on what they do to
protect their family
within the bounds of law so people do
what they can to to protect the
situation they're in and that is fine
but
when you're an elected official the
rules are different
okay the expectations are different we
literally elected you
to deal with this type of thing to lead
in times of crisis
so for you to leave that's literally not
doing your job the only time when it
really really matters
that to me was so infuriating and um
he's taken a lot of heat for it
that is well well well deserved and the
reality is this
say what you want about beto o'rourke
and i don't agree with everything and
that he you know all of his policies if
you will
but he never would have left texas never
and has it now now sadly
any press is good press in this day and
age so god forbid this probably helps
ted cruz in the long run
in terms of his like electability and
popularity and name id but
um still absurd and for those of you in
the yang gang or those of you who are
listening in that are in texas
um we are praying for you um
i'm donating to causes that can help um
particularly those less fortunate i have
a good friend i have a number of good
friends in texas
and one of them said she said i was like
how are you doing are you guys holding
up a case she said zach
imagine being a girl going outside in
negative 14 degrees
or 14 degrees outside i don't know
freezing cold it's sleeting and you're
trying to pee standing up in the wind
she's like it's been a disaster
um but that said she said look we were
fortunate enough to have
a home and a fireplace and blankets
and have access to food and a lot of
people don't have that same luxury so
it's rough for us but we are fine
there's millions of families hundreds of
thousands of families really struggling
so our prayers are going out to you um
and i believe help is on the way where
joe biden believe just declared a
federal emergency funds to the state of
texas so hopefully
aid is getting to those who need it most
and for those of you
in texas we are praying for you and
hopefully trying to help you
as much as we can speaking of help the
third thing i want to talk about guys i
just wanted to pause
because we haven't done this enough and
i just want to say to the yang gang and
those who supported andrew particularly
early on
i just want to say i love you this will
say freaking love you
it hasn't been a fun year particularly
um
it's we lost the presidential election
then covet hit
and this community and family that look
it wasn't perfect but it was
it was us it was love it was it was full
of the right things full of humanity
first and
a belief in something bigger than us and
it felt ripped apart a bit
um and a very stressful time a stressful
election that happened
um and here we are now and
you've got press hitting andrew like
every day you know and
even me at times getting their names
dragged through the mud it's all day
every day and it's um
during this so many of you have reached
out to andrew
have posted online have reached out to
me and you've sent love
and you've sent positivity and i just
wanted to say i love you
and andrew loves you and we appreciate
it um we love you right back
and look the bottom line is andrew yang
and myself
have always always always done this
and are doing this right now for the
right reasons and that reason is simple
we want to save our country
we want to say the country we love the
people we love in it
and leave a better place for our kids
something we can be proud of for our
our children and their children um and
that has not changed from day one now i
promise you
it would be a lot easier to just go
frankly like go back into
corporate america and make money um or
be an entrepreneur um
it is a lot easier to do that frankly
but that wouldn't solve what we're
fighting for
and uh so i wanted to say i love you
guys and and stay strong eyes on the
prize stephen covey says keep the the
main thing is keep the main thing the
main thing
and that's the main thing folks i'm
trying to save the world
i love you to death thank you and those
of you like trash talk me on twitter
fine love you too
i love you guys let's bring on rokano
roadcon is represented from california's
17th district
we love row we had a lot of similar
supporters
um he's a lot of sport in the tech
community in the asian community just
like
us he was the co-chair for bernie
sanders 2020
presidential campaign and
one of the few who actually stood up and
said where's the two thousand dollar
check to all americans um during coven
and oh god forbid if that does not
happen we will be very very upset but
ro khan has been in our camp he's a
great man
it's a great interview you're going to
love it it's a conversation about the
inner workings of politics and what's
going on
in our political world today so enjoy it
ro khanna
joins yang speaks
[Music]
all right new sponsor alert i want to
tell you guys about parachute
because parachute essentially their goal
is to make people feel at home
and their ex their let's call it tagline
is making home your happy place and i
just got my sheets
and towels and a bathrobe from parachute
and i promise you they are making my
home a happy place
they are so comfortable it's like lying
on a cloud i don't
explain it it's like soft and beautiful
and warm and fuzzy
and i promise you it's freaking amazing
and i literally this is so stupid but i
look forward to taking a shower because
i get to wrap myself in those freaking
towels
it's like butter i'll explain it it's
amazing so
make home your happy place check out
parachute home they have like it's not
just
towels they've got rugs they got all
this in-home softness
i don't know how to explain it but you
have to check it out so parachute
home.com so parachute like the thing you
used to jump out airplanes parachute
home
dot com slash yang you get free shipping
free returns you can try it out
parachutes very comfortable premium
quality home
essentials you're gonna love it check it
out
[Music]
[Applause]
it is my pleasure and privilege to
welcome
to yank speaks my good friend one of the
great hopes
for the country congressman representing
silicon valley co-chair of the bernie
sanders campaign
freaking public policy genius fighter
for the people
ro khanna welcome bro my andrew the
admiration is mutual and uh
you've uh helped put the
uh idea of giving monthly checks on uh
people's radar i remember when you were
running on that
people mocked you uh and now uh it has
become
the consensus opinion in this country
that uh how we should
address it so you certainly have been
vindicated
one of the many things you've advocated
for
well thank you ro you always saw it uh
you and i
were um connected before my presidential
run
uh and you were one of the people that
was trying to expand the benefits of
silicon valley to different parts of the
country
uh you drafted the internet bill of
rights which is a fantastic
uh bill that you know i i certainly hope
becomes pretty much like i'm a fan of so
many of your bills
and one of the things i want to talk
about today is really how
people can help you um get some of these
bills passed
because uh you would you and i
like if people watching are listening to
this to the extent that you're fans of
mine
um if you can imagine me in congress
like that's pretty much row like
rose just there like hatching up
policies and everything else but let's
give
people a chance to get to know you a
little bit better and you and i have a
lot in common too we're also in our
mid-40s children
immigrants you know you also went to law
school
but how did you arrive in congress
in california because that's a very uh
a very unusual uh position to find
yourself in
so i grew up in pennsylvania my folks
are still there in bucks county
uh and uh after law school i had
uh a professor larry lessig who uh you
know wrote
larry lessig he's been on the podcast so
he was uh
i never had them for class but i was a
research assistant for him
and he just kind of offendedly said look
the most interesting thing the
intersection of technology and law and
policy
is out of the value ought to come out
here and i i went out
uh i had a job at a law firm as a summer
associate that wilson sassini that did
tech work and i was just uh so intrigued
by
the place and the possibilities and uh
never left so that's that's how i made
it out there
uh it also happens to be that in fremont
they actually play
cricket and i said where else in the
country do you have all these cultures
all these uh
people from all over over the world so
uh
that's what drew me out there and then
uh and now
it's a great honor to be able to
represent the place in congress
you skipped over a bunch of stuff too
man weren't you like deputy assistant
secretary of commerce under obama and
some other
um pretty major milestones in there well
so the
ron i'm actually proud of stuff which i
lost uh 72 to 19
uh is my i ran against the war of
in iraq and against the patriot act
against an incumbent in my own party
in my late 20s it was a a protest run
but my grandfather is
as you know was spent uh years in uh
jail with with gandhi during the indian
independence movement and so i've always
been very passionate about
human rights and i thought the iraq war
was a disaster the patriot act which was
profiling at the time south asians
was really something that i opposed and
and after that i
got involved in the community with the
party uh
supported president obama uh you know
interestingly enough i had worked
on uh obama's first campaign when he was
running for the state senate if i worked
i mean
he's probably spent four hours uh
knocking on doors or standing outside a
shopping center
it didn't dawn on me until much later in
my life that he had already had that
race won
and you just had some students basically
doing the
the formality of outreach but anyway i
had a letter which he had signed
probably to every student who had done
anything for him
and i i sent that in along with my
everything else and
so i tell people it's really easy to go
work for the president you just when
you're in college you have to figure out
who's going to be president in 15 years
and
get them to work on one of their
campaigns so maybe they'll work on your
one of your campaigns and uh but that
that
uh in certain circumstance let me at uh
to commerce and
uh and the reality is you know with all
these positions is yes you have to be
passionate but you also have to
uh have the confidence of of the
presidential team
but i loved my job it was all about
bringing manufacturing back
increasing exports i worked under gary
locke
one of the things i say is you know we
would send gary locke to negotiate with
china china wasn't sending an american
someone of american origin to negotiate
with us
gary lock and i spoke just two days ago
believe it or not um
you know he he's been a role model of
mine for obvious reasons because he's
like the first
asian-american governor of washington
and a lot of other and secretary of
commerce
um so i guess he was your boss for a
little while before you went back to
congress
and then ran for congress won and now
you've been doing phenomenal work
i will say ro and
at the time you and i weren't uh as uh
friendly as we are now
um but i was a little hurt when you
chose bernie over me
well you didn't do a warfare's
resolution with me andrea i mean if you
were a congressman we had tried to stop
the yemen war together
uh you know i would have picked you up
for let's see how it is
you and bernie there trying to pass laws
trying to keep
the us out of wars and just because i
wasn't there
no one of my favorite moments for the
presidential debate is when you uh
told elizabeth warren uh you know oh
you're so excited elizabeth warren had
read your book and i thought
what a moment of of humanity because i'm
in the process of writing the book and i
had the same thought i'd loved it i'd be
thrilled if elizabeth warren
uh read my book and bernie sanders and
so uh
it was this i don't know if you remember
the moment but i remember
i remember that moment so
you're writing a book that's very
exciting can you share what it's about
sure it's actually about expanding
access to the digital economy
and in rural communities and black and
brown communities but more broadly also
applying the principles of democracy
uh to the digital age this idea that uh
the social media platforms that just by
creating platforms of communication
that we'd somehow have more deliberation
or pieces turned out not to be true
partly because they've targeted us
you mean these social media companies
haven't made us all smarter bro we're
not all like much more sophisticated
and educated unfortunately not but it's
the it's the early stages right i mean
the interesting thing with the printing
press you go back you look at the
history
it took like hundreds of years when the
printing press actually because of
written works was
leading the reactions of actually war
and conflict and it took
building of liberal institutions to now
come to a consensus that
the printing press obviously is a great
dissemination and knowledge but that
it wasn't also creating violent
reactions so we're just 20 years into
social media
it could be enormous in organizing but
we've got to think through
what are the forms of communication the
rules of communication and how do we
give people more choice and not have uh
targeting based on
based on our uh data and in the ways
that facebook has been
doing it well that's one of the things
you're trying to solve for with your
internet bill of rights
um so you're in the midst of this in a
way that very few others are
my sense of things is that there are
some very well intended legislators like
yourself
who understand what's going on with
their data that is getting sold and
resold in ways that are
bad for democracy bad for our mental
health uh bad economics and that you
know it's worth hundreds of billions of
dollars and we're not seeing a dime
the financial incentives are not serving
us well uh and then you have your home
state of california that's actually the
leader
in uh consumer data rights my sense of
things is that this legislation
is kind of stuck in congress and that
it's more likely that various states end
up following california's lead
then that congress passes something that
mirrors uh
the california privacy act um is that
accurate because i'm sure you have your
finger on the pulse of what the
legislation looks like and i hope i'm
wrong because i'd be down if there were
federal legislation
we may get federal legislation with
shikaski but let me
go into some detail here because i know
you and and your listeners will
appreciate it
here's the challenge with both the gdpr
in europe and
uh california's uh consumer rights and
why we need a beef
ftc and fcc and the federal government
to act
one look at the european funds yesterday
or a couple days ago i read
that italy found that facebook misused
their uh their data so they're finding
them
seven million dollars i mean give me a
break the facebook's not going
to you know you saw illinois there was a
civil settlement for 650 million dollars
which
at least like would hit their radar
screen
you know probably it's an intern would
known as a seven million dollar fine
the second thing is that this is a the
more important thing
so when they have these consent it turns
out there was this paper done
that these tech companies have been able
through graphics and placement
basically get people to click on uh
yes i consent almost 80 90 of
no one knows what we're agreeing to none
of us yeah i mean you and i went to law
school we still have no idea what we're
agreeing to half the time
exactly and so even with all the good
language of the gender so what does this
mean we actually need like tech
competent people in enforcement agencies
at the ftc fcc and we've got to have
uh very uh them at the table in
in defining these laws i don't think a
state by state approach or just the
european approach
is going to be any match for these
companies and i see them they're in my
district
and so we absolutely need federal
legislation but more than that we need
the enforcement
and tech competent people in those
agencies who can say no you can't have
manipulative design these dark patterns
that basically are manipulating people
into consent all right yank speaks is
brought to you by
athletic greens this is the most
comprehensive daily nutritional beverage
i've ever tried
i'm not the best at eating well and in
covid if you're ordering like
your habits are all like you don't
really have the right routine and
athletic greens can help just making
sure you get all the veggies and all the
vitamins and all the things you're
supposed to have
in a balanced diet so one scoop of
athletic greens got 17 vitamins minerals
whole food source ingredients it's got a
multivitamin a multi-mineral probiotic
green superfood blends like one of those
green smoothies and a little pout
it's awesome and they work together to
fill the nutritional gaps in your diet
increases your energy get a little more
focus all these good things so
you guys need to check this out go to
athleticgreens.com
yang and join health experts athletes
and health conscious go-getters around
the world to make a daily commitment to
their health every day
and athletic greens is doubling down on
supporting your immune system during the
winter months they're offering our
audience a
free one-year supply of vitamin d and
five
free travel packs with your first
purchase if you visit our link today so
you never have to buy vitamin d
again it's amazing so that's
athleticgreens.com
yang get your free supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs
today
[Music]
[Applause]
what do you see as the prospects of
federal legislation and these
enforcement resources that could
actually balance the scales
uh because i agree with you that right
now government is outcome
well i think we it's going to take more
people caring about it right for so long
it was just
that's just a techie issue it's just
privacy why should i care about privacy
here's why you should care because 64 of
people on facebook
who joined q anon were there with
facebook recommendations to join you're
now on these public
facebook made some money off of it yeah
the whole thing is messed up
so if you care about the radicalization
of our country and the polarization on
social media
we've got to care about how our
information is being used not just
because of your privacy
because your privacy decision affects
the state of our democratic discourse
and so
what the reason we don't have action on
this frankly is we don't have the
mobilization no one is out there on my
very few people are calling me and
saying bro we need privacy legislation
we need social media regulated they're
calling me and saying
understandably we need 15 minimum wage
and other issues but until we have
mobilization
this is just going to continue to be uh
stalled
i'm 100 with you that most people don't
understand the urgency
of uh federal data
and privacy legislation and enforcement
resources
because right now the tech companies are
running circles around everybody
uh and and there's not even like uh like
uh
a principal debate that's happening that
that is accurate at all like most
legislators just don't understand the
set of issues
but one thing i really admired about
your presidential campaign is you had a
clear theory of the case which i
happen to share which is in part that
we're going through a digital revolution
that is fundamentally transforming
society it's
leaving communities out of wealth
generation and out of the possibility of
staying in their own communities and
doing well
and it's also making it much diff more
difficult to have
democrat conversation but it's sort of
like we're going and
attacking uh discrete parts of the issue
without seeing that there's this
huge there's a centralized disease in
the middle of it man the center
like the like the social media networks
like this tentacle beast in the middle
of the whole thing
if someone wanted to help would it be
helpful if they were to reach out to
their member of congress and say hey
like get behind this federal data
legislation like what can the average
citizen do
absolutely so shikowsky's uh bill is the
is the
uh the bill on privacy legislation that
would
get passed and it's still being uh
worked on but i think just being part of
the conversation and saying this is
something that we ought to care about
having ideas sending us there
the ideas for that uh and it's and
insisting that this should be part of
the agenda for
uh 2022 that this has to be
a high priority let's do it people write
your members of congress let them know
that you think the fed should pass
legislation protecting our data rights
and making it so that there's actual
enforcement of those rights and that's
not the tech companies laughing all the
way to the bank
uh so that's one thing you're working on
but that's not even the main thing
um you're working on uh trying to get
cash out to people is that correct which
obviously
i am 100 behind
[Laughter]
well you helped with uh helping tim ryan
and i conceived of this we were calling
to this in march with your
advocacy at help which said let's get
people two thousand dollar checks uh
partly i read one of the most compelling
studies which is that
so many people i think i read up to 75
percent of people are unemployed aren't
getting the unemployment benefits and
i had to re-read it to uh really get
that sure that's true
yeah so yeah but people either don't
know about it or don't have the
uh wherewithal to be able to get them so
the best way
is just get people these checks uh and
uh
they will spend it locally they'll make
sure they want their houses aren't
getting foreclosed on they'll be able to
help with rent or help the small
business landlords i mean a lot of
people who aren't uh
paying the rent we're forgetting about
the small businesses that are being hurt
so
i don't understand why if we find these
trillions of dollars to be
bailing out everything else eight
trillion is what we've spent uh
so far as a as a country why we can't
get some of the money for the work again
so you say it's eight cares was like 2.2
uh are you including this massive number
that went to the
uh financial markets like uh yeah did
you get eight
yeah that's what i read with it when you
look at what both the fed has done
and the uh and what uh the congress has
done and of course there were a number
of other packages
uh as well if you sum up all of that uh
that is about the spending but
the the american people does the eight
include the new 1.9 that we think will
pass in march
no no no this is before that would be
ten
and it'll be ted by your time yeah
someone should do this
someone should have a breakdown of how
much money directly went to the american
people
and how much did uh the government spend
and
you know it's it makes no sense why you
wouldn't have both
it makes no sense at all man i mean i
tried to do the math on the cares act
and you could have given every american
um
like six thousand dollars for the amount
that was in the cares act instead of
what do we get i think we got
uh well maybe 1200 yeah yeah like you
could have
like you know made that five times
bigger and still had money to spare
so there was the bill that you and tim
championed which i loved
the two thousand dollars uh a month bill
i think it got at least like dozens of
supporters
what is what is the status of cash
relief right now i get the sense that
joe biden um and the team are saying
fourteen hundred dollars for everyone as
part of this 1.9 trillion dollar
stimulus bill
i think yes and then and then are there
separate bills that are on the table
that we can uh push and uh and try and
get
passed into law well tim and i still had
the emergency people act uh
bill and so we're pushing right now
obviously to get the
uh the 1400 and not to uh to means test
it in ways i mean
there were some of people who wanted to
means test it where biden would end up
giving less than the means testing that
trump was talking about so
that that was not off the table
we'll get the uh fourteen hundred
dollars and then the question is that
there's gotta be something recurring and
that's the real fight that when the next
round of
uh stimulus comes up covered relief
comes up can we
be providing people with uh with relief
until we're past
the uh past the pandemic well
love this bill that you and tim uh
co-sponsored how many people are on that
bill like
and how many people do you think we need
we're over 50 we
you know getting over 100 is always the
magic number uh
and i appreciate uh everything you and
a lot of your uh followers have done to
build support for this
job number two everyone emergency money
for the people act get your member of
congress to sign
on if we get 50 more then it passes the
100 mark and then all of a sudden
uh you'll see articles written about it
all these people will have to opine on
it
so we're halfway there in my mind this
stuff really should be a no-brainer
because
we're spending hundreds of billions of
dollars on all sorts of stuff
and most of it is not falling into the
hands and lives of the american people
it's very frustrating it's like like
it's getting pumped into various
uh pipes and institutions with the
theoretical purpose that it will reach
us
but most of it does not reach us so if
you if you want to have the money reach
us you get to send it to us
and row is trying to make that happen so
so
thankful to you and tim um and everyone
else who's fighting for it
no i appreciate your portfolio and some
people say well why do folks need it who
haven't lost their jobs i said have you
seen
coleman over the last 10 months i mean
people are having to
spend more time taking care of their
kids people are having to spend more
time at home people are having to
much greater burdens in terms of uh
things they need to
uh to be able to deal in a in a remote
economy
or uh others are having to cut back an
hour so it is a
this is not just all the only only the
unemployed need this help that it's just
a uh
very myopic way of looking at it i could
not agree more
like the metaphor i use all the time ro
is like
with when the house is on fire you turn
on the fire hoses and you spray it down
with water
what you don't worry about is like oh
did some of the water splash
on a part of the house that wasn't on
fire
that's not the way you think about it i
mean like we're still in the midst of a
historic crisis people are in food lines
for miles
uh people are still losing their lives
uh many people are still losing their
livelihoods i mean i i'm
in new york city and there are
restaurants that have been hanging on
that are now closing so like
the struggles are everywhere uh and
anyone who imagines that we can
somehow like allocate dollars like very
very precisely
only to like certain people like it's
just not realistic it's like we're much
better off
driving it out to people particularly
because it's our money anyway i mean
like we're the freaking
uh you know citizens owners and
stakeholders of this economy it's like
like
you know it's like it's like whenever a
company
gives the shareholders dividends that no
one looks around and it's like oh why
did you do
that like there was a rich shareholder
in there that's not the way it works at
all
and they're going to spend it and create
jobs and that's going to bring more tax
revenue back so
uh the the it's actually shown by
economists they have
a huge stimulus effect a huge job
creation effect
it's the right policy it's just a matter
of uh and now getting the political will
to do it
but you're looking at an impact they
know because we've at least gotten
correct checks believe it or not that
was not part of our policy before so
even though we've had only a 1200 600
now we'll have a 1400
check i mean the fact that this was the
issue in the entire georgia senate race
i mean would you ever
guess that they're running on 2 000
checks as the defining issue of
who controls the senate so uh i say all
of this because
uh progress could be slow and painful
but to
see where you were when you announced
the idea of giving a monthly check and
to see where we've come
should give your uh followers and
supporters a lot of uh
optimism well certainly i i'm very
grateful to everyone who supported my
campaign because i feel like
we helped make it happen i'm thrilled
that there are conscientious legislators
like you
actually writing bills and passing them
to try and get money out to people
[Music]
are you losing your mind because i am
incovid i
am a little more stressed i'm a little
more short-tempered
i sometimes just want to bang my head
against the wall i feel lethargic
and right now it's really helpful to
talk to somebody and that's why i want
to talk to you guys about better help
better help is a way to connect with
someone to talk to
in a safe and private online environment
it's super convenient you can start
communicating in under 48 hours it's not
a crisis line it's not even self-help
really it's just
professional counseling done securely
online so you can send a message to your
counselor anytime
you get these timely thoughtful
responses and schedule weekly phone or
video sessions and so you can specialize
and talk to specialists in
depression stress anxiety relationships
sleeping grief all of it
i've been doing it's great keeps me sane
i love it so
i want you to start living a happier
life today and as a listener you're
going to get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor
betterhelp.com yang that's
betterhelphelp.com join over one million
people have taken charge their mental
health like us
betterhelp.com
so now we've got everyone like members
of congress know that you care about
what's happening to your data number two
is definitely emergency money for the
people act i mean that's mission
critical
uh that that i'd say is like you know
number one
um in terms of people's immediate needs
uh
what else are you working on because i
know there's there's one bill of yours i
love the cheaters act but i don't know
if that's like
the like the your top priority so we'd
love to hear what your number three
would be
well let's talk about the cheaters act
there are two other priorities but the
cheaters act is important because it's
so simple it says
that you can raise 1.2 trillion dollars
in this country
just by enforcing the uh
taxes on the biggest corporations and
the one percent we're not talking about
going after tax avoidance we're not
talking about
clever schemes that rich people have to
avoid uh
paying tax and deductions we're talking
about actual tax of asia that is illegal
that is not being enforced by the irs
because the irs doesn't have the staff
to audit
the the one percent or large
corporations they're spending their time
auditing instead people who get the
earned income tax credit and
get 25 000 uh salaries are being audited
at a greater rate in certain states than
uh the wealthiest are so the bill says
uh let's actually uh audit uh the
people who are most likely to be uh uh
evading
and that will raise 1.2 trillion by the
way larry summers uh
is idea larry summers and another uh
economics professor
it's another no-brainer honestly like
the irs's entire budget is around 10
billion dollars
there was at least one estimate i saw
that said um we're leaving 400
billion in taxes on the table
so it's like wait a minute like this is
what you're saying it's like look if you
just actually enforce the laws on the
books
like you would end up generating
hundreds of billions of dollars
in revenue just based upon the rules as
they're written now uh because right now
the irs is auditing something like a
third of one percent
of like the you know like the big
companies and the highest earners and so
you know
there's all sorts of like um you know
like people taking advantage of it uh
has this bill been introduced and what
are its prospects i'm a huge fan of the
cheaters act i think the acronym is
funny as hell too
it's been introduced and actually this
is something i think that could unite
the democratic party
because look we may disagree on uh
whether we should have a wealth tax or
not i'm foreign we may disagree with
progressive taxation but this is just
saying
everyone should play for by the same
rules and you can raise 1.2 trillion
in fact most rich people should be for
this you're rich and you've actually
been paying your taxes
which most people actually do based on
the data shouldn't it bother you that
there are these
20 30 or not paying taxes or hurting the
country hurting the image of those are
wealthy so this is just about
fairness and i i'm hopeful that uh the
binding administration gets behind this
as probably the low-hanging fruit of how
the democratic party can
raise revenue and even some republicans
maybe maybe for it
i hope it uh gets passed because it's a
great idea it's just like look
um i'm not even going to argue with you
about like where to draw the line i'm
just going to say we should enforce the
lines as they're currently
it's very very smart uh so it sounds
like you had a couple of other things
that are on your your priority list
because this is great this is a great
list
what's number four well one is your
senator and i uh schumer and i have a
bill called the endless frontiers which
is bipartisan it's got
uh mike gallagher republican marine for
wisconsin and uh
todd young senator from indiana and it
is a hundred billion dollar
investment in the uh national science
foundation to make it the national
science and technology foundation
to create uh investments in ai so that
we're not just dependent on large data
ai
synthetic biology uh cyber security
quantum computing and of tech hubs in
different parts of the country
uh this is in my view necessary for
competitiveness it's necessary for
job creation uh you and i have talked
about the relationship with china while
we need to in my view be
tough and smart we also it shouldn't be
replicating a paradigm of a cold war and
this is actually the way to win the 21st
century let's actually
out compete let's out innovate uh the
the rest of the world so
uh schumer has said that this is a huge
priority for him in the senate
uh i'm pushing this in the house uh this
fits in with biden's buildback better
uh and we have a real shock to get this
across the finish line
well i love it uh science and technology
investment at the highest levels makes
perfect sense
it'll pay for itself many times over in
national competitiveness a lot of our
biggest innovations came out of
public dollars uh you know including
some of the technologies behind spacex
and tesla which
now everyone associates with you know
like
uh elon and the rest of it but like elon
readily acknowledges
it's like look like you know like some
of this stuff um came out of the fence
uh so that's number four uh that's also
a slam dunk in a home run
um and then you had one other that's on
your mind uh the fifth
so the fifth is one of the things i did
with senator sanders which was we passed
for the first time in the history of the
country the war powers resolution to
stop the yemen war uh president buying
into his verdict
has announced that uh the u.s is going
to shift policy we're no longer
going to be supporting the saudi in
their offensive bombing
in yemen why should people care uh the
country of yemen faces a famine of
unbelievable it's a humanitarian crisis
it's wrong
i actually just yesterday spent time
with the yemeni american community
they're lovely wonderful people and it
has been painful for them to see what's
going on in their home country
there's actually been an influx of
people from yemen because
and they did not want to leave yemen but
uh but the conflict
has driven people out because people
feared for their lives um so it's a
humanitarian crisis the united states
has not done enough to stop it i mean
you know we have not done enough to stop
it yeah man
unfortunately for years we've been
complicit and we were actually yeah i
know i was about to say we kind of
abetted it
but i i thought i'd be a little bit uh
diplomatic but but that's what even even
people
at the highest level of government uh
understand that that we were
on the wrong side of this and that means
that we can't just wash our hands and
say okay now that we've stopped thanks
to president biden
uh let's just uh leave it be we have in
my view
given the role we played a moral
obligation to help this war end
and how do we help the war end we've got
to tell the saudis
iran and the uae all sides to stop
pouring money stop pouring arms
into yemen uh let the u.n peace
negotiator martin griffiths
help resolve it if it becomes a civil
war in yemen that at least has a chance
at peace when you have all of these
actors
that are pouring money in uh the war
will never end
so congress has played a major role here
and it's something that i'm going to
continue to push for
thank goodness for you and bernie
pushing for this i mean uh it would be
a tremendous uh positive
if um we could somehow ease the conflict
in yemen
and and diminish the forces that are
right now fueling it
the news has gone sideways in many ways
and it's one of the reasons i like the
new yorker
in print and online the new yorker kind
of stands apart because commitment to
truth and accuracy and it's got really
quality writing compelling reporting and
storytelling and i love it because it's
not always politics
um so they've got weekly print but
they've got daily online articles that
cover this full range of topics so not
just politics but there's news
international fair climate change
the environment pop culture arts fiction
food humor cartoons you name it one
article i was reading was on an
unethical ai which i am fascinated by
and i want to cover on here this guy
matthew hudson wrote a pretty
fascinating piece on what a.i
could look like um down the road so i
want you guys to check this out so for a
limited time you can get 12 weeks of the
new yorker for literally six
bucks that's a savings of 50 percent
they're giving you a big discount
because you're listening to yang speaks
plus listeners of the show get an
exclusive tote bag for free
can't get anywhere else right here so go
to newyorker.com
yang that's
n-e-w-y-o-r-k-e-r-dot-com-slash-yang to
get 12 weeks in the new yorker for just
six dollars and you get a free tote bag
carry around
so newyorker.com
[Music]
[Applause]
so row you supported bernie uh which
i appreciated a great deal despite my
joking earlier um
uh you know joe won um bernie
is there in the senate making good
things happen you're in congress making
good things happen
what is the legislative climate right
now like how are you feeling
how does the progressive caucus feel
like do you feel like you're going to be
able to get big things done
um do you have a sense of what the
administration's legislative priorities
are so you're like oh well maybe we can
like i get the sense that their next big
move is going to be infrastructure
after uh after this uh coveted relief
bill goes out and i'm completely down
with the fact that
everything is being um uh
focused on this copyright bill because
you know like this thing passing is
uh job one but yeah like what what is
the insider's point of view
on um what you believe that the
opportunities are
and the legislative climate right now
so the progressive caucus actually has
finally become a force
uh which is which is having an impact i
mean there was talk as you followed of
stripping out the minimum wage the 15
wage even from the house bill
we pushed back it's going to be in uh
the legislation at least i planned
the house you know we're pushing that
we've got to get to the point where
we're taking advantage of all the
procedural uh steps to get things done
uh and that means in my view that it
should be done on reconciliation and
if the parliamentarian goes against it
we can we should overrule the
parliamentarian of the parliamentary
that was
said that the aca can be repealed
through reconciliation and you can't
give people a raise
uh so that's something that we're
pushing for
uh we're pushing to make sure we push
back against the means testing on these
checks so that
we weren't having to cut off that we
succeeded fighting is a has some
good things in that 1.9 truly the most
important in my view is the child tax
credit
which columbia university has said uh
would cut child poverty in half i mean
it's almost 3 600
for families with kids that's an
incredibly progressive policy
huge yeah and uh and and biden deserves
credit for having it
so i think you what you see is binding
started off in a in my view of
a a pretty good place the progressive
caucus has had
a constructive influence and uh and it
looks like we're going to pass this on
reconciliation so we're not waiting
around
uh and diluting it uh for mythical
republican votes i'm all for
bipartisanship as the endless frontiers
suggested no i mean
but there's a reason why i was in
georgia fighting it out man it's like
i could see very clearly that if you had
to have mitch mcconnell signing off on
things or whatever
like you know can you imagine what this
bill would even look like
in that world it would be like a
completely different bill
to give you a sense of mcconnell the the
fact is that we had this bill schumer
and i last
session and we have two republicans it's
about science and technology investment
in our competitiveness right it's not
even about everybody sure
it should be everyone and mcconnell
wasn't willing to move that so now when
you're talking about well let's give
working class americans a raise
you understand the the obstacles and i
often put if you couldn't get
uh donald trump to have 60 votes of
conviction
in the senate uh not i mean you needed
67 but you couldn't even get 60.
you understand that i mean those are the
people you have to convince to overcome
the filibuster so that's just not
realistic
i was making the same argument to people
when like in georgia some people were
like don't you want checks and balances
bipartisanship and i was like that is
not the choice in front of you
the choice is a government that will
actually uh be able to meaningfully
respond to this crisis
or not and so if you want your
government to be able to do anything
you have to get like uh you know these
democratic senators in
uh i am so pumped that chuck schumer is
the senate majority leader i spoke to
him the other day
um uh you know in passing he's doing a
great job actually he's
he's really pushing the envelope and has
really reached out to all of us in the
progressive caucus and
and wants to be bold he gets it gets the
moment and he understands
the arcane procedures of the senate
which you have to understand
to be effective uh uh yeah chuck seems
like he's doing
tremendous work um and if you can
imagine from his perspective he's been
waiting for this freaking job for a
while
i always thought he's trying to make the
most of it as you are trying to make the
most out of your roll row
so people want to support you um
individually
please do follow row on social media
he's very active what else can people do
to fuel
your work um either individually or
legislatively
um or getting uh their own members of
congress excited about some of these
issues
well i love what you've done uh andrew
because you've inspired a movement
around the country and i think people
one they can engage with me and you can
tweet at me and i actually get good
ideas from folks and see i engage with
folks you can email me at row
rowconna.com when you are on social
media if you're talking to your member
of congress
don't assume that they aren't going to
pay attention let me tell you members of
congress pay attention so
yes uh we can't go and meet members of
congress right now with a pandemic
but be active on the issues you care
about on social media
just take that link to the emergency
money for the people actually just like
send it to your congressman
like i i did that about a affair about
what i will say is the there is such
creativity
there is such ingenuity uh outside of
washington and i don't say i have a lot
of respect for public servants i have a
lot of respect
i don't say this is some sort of
broadside against everyone in washington
i just say that
we need new thinking we need new ideas a
lot of your
uh supporters volunteers have those send
them in i mean
almost all the good ideas i've had have
come from
someone else who i just listened to and
i said okay let's run with that
and i i just think we need an infusion
of that kind of thinking in congress
well that's one of the things i learned
from you ro when we had a conversation
before
like you talked about the seniority
based system in congress
uh you know you showed up um and then
and i love the fact that now you're
finding
points of leverage where you're like
okay how am i going to get things done
uh you know within this vast legislative
body some people have been there
uh 18 20 30 years you know like
the rest of it um and uh
like you're the perfect combination of
wanting to get a lot of stuff done
um envision um uh but also
um you know you're a coalition builder
you're practical like you're gonna
be like okay like um you know what are
the goals that i can accomplish and who
can i get on board with them
i'm so grateful you're in congress doing
what you're doing
i'm grateful that it's you representing
silicon valley i think you're a
fantastic blend
of both the future uh regarding
uh tech oriented policies but mostly
like you're looking out for people uh
you know and
you're trying to to meld those two
things um
and hopefully we can make it so that
it's working for both
uh like the average person and the
innovator
well i appreciate that andrew i feel
similar about you and why your
campaign was historic and what you're
going to be doing next is
it's so important uh not just because
you
broke every barrier as an asian american
and uh
took that taken seriously at the
presidential scale by the way that's
no a small feat i mean when i was
growing up i don't know what when you
were growing up but the idea that you
could have an asian american become a
major presidential candidate
uh seemed pretty far uh
it certainly wasn't coming out up in the
yang household
[Laughter]
but but but you did something more
important i saw that when you had the
math
math signs i mean you started talking
about the real issues for this country
and that and the question is this for us
are we going to just settle uh for a
a decline a a sense that
uh things aren't uh uh what they used to
be or are we gonna offer a vision that
no
these next 50 hundred years are going to
be america's greatest we're going to
take this incredible diversity and we're
going to have
innovation and we're going to be
inclusive and we're going to have
radical equality and democracy
and we're going to build something for
our country that we've never seen before
a multi-racial multi-ethnic democracy
that's working that's innovating and by
the way this is the model that's going
to win the 21st century we're not going
to replicate cold wars we're not going
to replicate
all the mistakes that were made of the
20s from our mistakes
from our past uh you know i think would
be more transformative than
the emergency money for the people like
passing i have to say
and really if you're listening to this
we're 50 members of congress away from
this becoming
uh you know something that's front and
center 85 percent of americans are for
casualty during the pandemic a majority
are for
universal basic income in perpetuity um
so we just have to get more
members uh excited about this bill
feel like it's a win for them feel like
they'll be seen looking out for people
because everything you just described
row about like us trying to build a
future that's working for us
um you know i i was so pained to see
that the united states of america right
now is 28th
in various uh social progress uh and
nowadays you probably saw the same
analysis
and these were things like infant
mortality
uh clean water public education
like like you know pretty basic stuff um
and so we were 28th and that was
pre-pandemic i have a feeling that
even our relative uh stature has
declined
because we've dealt with covid so much
more disastrously than
a lot of other societies like
if you're looking for us to be able to
actually
build the society we want for the future
nothing is going to be more powerful
than getting resources into people's
hands
and i know that your pushing for it is
dramatically
increasing the chances of it happening
every single day
so i just want everyone to get behind
you to be excited about you the way i am
like
i see you as a real kindred spirit and
uh
you know not just because we both are
parents with two kids
and like you know like uh and uh you
know
children of immigrants and like breaking
various barriers
uh but because you and i have very
similar uh
views on both the problems of the
present and what the future
could be uh i'm just really glad you're
in congress man
i'm like a huge admirer of yours as one
of my friends said to me
uh during uh when you were running and
he said you and andrew are a lot
uh alike in ways if you just had his
charisma i said wow all right
so i said i don't know i mean i guess
that
they in your own way so uh
but i i i think look we you're gonna
whatever you do next
and i you're gonna be part of the next
generation of of leadership you've
already had an
incredible influence on congress i mean
i uh
don't want to uh underestimate or put
your supporters on your estimate what
you did
the idea of sending people checks
as a response it was laughed at
initially when you put it
and now we're debating okay how long do
we do it and what the income level is
but
you've changed right just like bernie
changed the debate fundamentally on
medicare for all
you know when he took that up and no one
was talking about it now it has the
majority
caucus you fundamentally have changed
the debate in the country
on cash assistance to people and more
broadly helping
uh put people first in in our
uh democracy and that's a you know
that's i think that's what people say
why do you do
politics you know when you can have an
impact like that and it's rare and
you may be doing things for years but
when that happens
uh there's no more gratifying feeling i
mean it's something that's actually
having an impact on people's lives
thank you bro well again it it's only
going to have an impact if legislators
like you
um uh make it a law and the policy of
the land but
um i will say to you on a personal level
uh i was incredibly proud i am
incredibly proud of the presidential
campaign
and there was part of me that was like
well if that's like my major
contribution
like i'm i'm okay with that like this is
like a
very very worthy contribution uh that
i've mainstreamed
cash leap in universal basic income uh
and then
you wake up the next day and then you're
just like okay
like uh uh what can i do to like
actually
like help get it across the finish line
oh i should not count my friend row i
should like
so it it's funny it's like um i am i
appreciate
uh the sentiment a great deal it means a
lot to me it means a lot to a lot of the
people that are listening to this
um but know that like we we still
uh have to um go from inspiration to
policy
um and i i feel like uh you know we did
open a lot of people's eyes and minds
and hearts um
but there's still a fight ahead of us
and i i really appreciate
you being one of the leaders in this
fight we're going to be with you every
step of the way
i appreciate it and i uh look forward to
uh engaging and being with the movement
you built
every step of the way and i guess let me
reflect on what you said because i think
there was something very profound
there where you said taking inspiration
and making it into policy
and it's uh if there's one thing i've
learned in my four
now going on five years and in dc it's
how hard that is i thought the hard
thing
oh
building the inspiration and that's a
necessary without that you can't even
get
started but even when you have the
mobilized inspiration it's amazing to me
how many things don't move
in washington and it's not always uh
corruption in the way you think of it i
was telling someone
who won't mention who but there was one
bill of mine that was clearly obvious
and it was a person one staff person in
one committee
who didn't like it and wanted to kill
the whole thing so if there are so many
ways
in washington to say no there's so many
ways to kill an idea there's so much
risk aversion in how we operate
uh and uh that it it it's it's a
uh herculean feat to do anything major
uh but when it happens when you do a
sustained mobilization that isn't just a
presidential campaign but
continues to fight which you've done for
uh cash uh relief
uh then you see that things can get done
and can
change and so i have admiration for your
supporters that they've
stuck with this stuck with you and have
gotten more engaged more involved after
your campaign than just saying okay we
did our thing
and we made our contribution to this
country i've learned from you what the
actual
obstacles are uh in terms of getting
some of these bills passed
is this going to be in your book because
i i would love to read like chapters and
chapters about like
like some of your experiences in
congress
i i'm gonna have some of it i try to i
try to focus on the ideas but i
i i do think that people probably would
want to know some of the
actual obstacles in in legislation i
think that is uh so
maybe i'll i'll include that do you
totally should and you should know that
that's where my head is going row
is because i i'm reflecting on the fact
that look if 55
of us are for universal basic income
problem solved right and then it's like
problem not solved at all because of the
stuff that you're
describing it's like you have to get
into the the machinery itself to figure
out what it would take
and it's not about the checks i mean
look if you put aside look there's
obviously some
issues of the powerful have way too much
of a voice and special interests and
lobbyists
but there's another fundamental issue
which is it's a difference between a
startup and ibm and there's a reason
that ibm
has all these safeguards because they're
wealthy and successful and they don't
want to take
risks that are uh too crazy and so some
of it is
understandable but here's the challenge
for us we're as america we're the ibm
but we're living in a world where just
being the ibm isn't going to be good
enough to be competitive
and the ibm has a lot of underlying
problems that need structural reform
so we need government reform not just of
saying okay i'm against the
special interests against the lobbyists
we need actual fundamental reform that
allows us to make decisions you are one
of like the
um best situated people to figure out
how to
actually turn our ibm
into uh you know into a 21st century
government
uh so count me in um that to me is our
next challenge
like you know that that and um it's the
mechanics it's the plumbing
um you know it's like like if you have
all this energy coming into
machinery that is uh like either
not responsive or or um like not aligned
or not adapting
uh you're just gonna get frustrated um
and so that that to me
has to be where our focus is so i'm
gonna be picking your brain a lot i urge
you definitely to include this in your
book
um when the book does come out we'll
have you back on so everyone can
uh can make sure to get a copy um
so excited uh that you are there finding
the good fight my friend
and uh we'll do everything we can to
help
thank you andrew and i look forward to
your implementing your 21st
century vision of government uh and uh
excited to be uh partnering with you for
the long run
you got it brother i will see you soon
thank you so much ro
thank you enjoyed it
[Music]
you